>>Presenter: All right.
Well, we're very pleased to have Dr. Oliver
Sacks with us today.
Dr. Sacks is a physician and a professor of
neurology and psychology at the Columbia University
Center.
He's also the author of more than ten books,
some of which I have here.
So for example, we have The Man Who Mistook
His Wife for a Hat.
Awakenings.
Musicophilia.
Seeing Voices.
And the most recent one today that we're going
to talk about is The Mind's Eye.
So please join me in welcoming Dr. Sacks.
[Applause]
>> Presenter: What I wanted to do is to ask
you questions about one of the last chapters.
It's 'persistence of vision' where you talk
about, you document your declining vision
in the right eye.
And as some background, at one point you make
reference to Edwin Abbott's Flatland, where
you say that you experienced -- you mention
that you experience your own overwhelming
flatness and that you lost your fear of heights.
So for those of you not familiar with Flatland,
can you describe what this life is like in
this fictional world and what resonated with
you about that?
>> Dr. Sacks: And this was a book which was
written in the 1880s.
And the inhabits of Flatland live seemingly
happily on a surface but there have been some
strange phenomena occurring in which objects
or people seem to emerge and get larger and
then disappear.
And then theoreticians say there must be another
dimension.
And although this seems very counterintuitive
to the people on Flatland.
But I think you probably have to read the
book.
I'm more conscious of my own Flatland than
that.
By the way, I need to make an apology to all
of you because I'm not only blind in my right
eye, but as happens with people who are blind
in one eye, there is sort of a hemineglect.
I have to remember that you are there.
This hemineglect has caused many bizarre situations.
So not only do I not see people -- say, get
into an elevator to my right, it doesn't occur
to me that anything would happen on my right.
[laughter]
>> Presenter:So with respect to your losing
your fear of heights, there's an image.
So immediately, I thought of this guy.
Man on wire.
And then the New York skyscraper scene.
That one.
And, for me, when I see that, I can't help
but feel queasy even though I know I'm not
sitting there.
It's two dimensional.
And so, I have a couple of questions.
One -- is it possible that people who can
perform under these conditions lack a sense
of depth.
>> Dr. Sacks: I doubt it, because lacking
a sense of depth is somewhat disabling especially
in situations like this, I would think, would
be fatal.
[laughter] But this lack of a sense of depth
is actually dangerous even for me, because
I am – I can't see the depth of steps and
I can't see the depth of the podium.
And I'm glad we are well on to it.
>> Presenter: So I don't have an explanation
for why I can't do that.
But in any case, I'll just live with that.
I'll never go there.
>> Dr. Sacks: I didn't like to look down at
all.
And I mention you are surprised at the absence
of autonomic reaction -- of fear.
But it seems to be so.
>>Presenter: So you mentioned you can be in
Topanga Canyon where you look down, you would
feel, you had that fear at that time, right.
When you would look down in the canyon but
now --
>> Dr. Sacks: Fear and thrill.
And now that particular fear and thrill is
gone.
I have other ones.
>> Presenter: [chuckles] I'm just curious
also why it is that I would feel queasy looking
at this?
What's happening there?
Any ideas.
>> Dr. Sacks: I'm not sure.
I suspect that something to do with your semicircular
canals, but maybe it's just, you know, your
bringing up
>> Presenter:My what?
>>Dr. Sacks: Maybe it's just your upbringing.
>> Presenter:Anybody else feel that?
Or am I the only one?
You're all safe.
[chuckles] All right.
So when you point out in your book that seeing
nothing on the right side which you've just
described now, you mention Federico the 15th
century Duke of Urbino, one of them, so I
thought of this guy who's about to appear.
Turns out that's him isn't it?
And so, I'm curious.
Do you guys?
Explain what this guy did.
>> Dr. Sacks: Well, he lost one eye.
And half -- nearly half of his visual field.
And he felt this made him very vulnerable
to attack on the blind side.
And so, he had his nose removed so that at
least something over here could be taken in
by the left eye.
>> Presenter:And it worked.
>> Dr. Sacks: He wasn't, I think assassinated.
[laughter]
>> Presenter:Okay, I guess that's evidence.
All right.
That answers that question.
Okay.
So you mention that the only time you see
in stereo now is when you're dreaming.
And you mention the Grand Canyon.
And I find that when I stand on the rim of
the Grand Canyon, it looks flat to me.
Do we have a Grand Canyon?
And in fact, it feels like I'm in the museum
of natural history.
>> Dr. Sacks: One doesn't have stereo beyond
about 200 feet or so.
>> Presenter:Okay.
>> Dr. Sacks: Although you can get stereo
beyond 200 feet, if you use a hyper stereoscope.
If you get a long cardboard tube and put in
oblique mirrors and then basically your eyes
are out here.
And then you can expand the Grand Canyon.
>>Presenter: So that's what I have to do next
time I go to the Grand Canyon.
We have another real picture.
There we go.
All right.
Moving right along.
The last chapter, the Mind's Eye chapter,
where these are people you discuss -- you
describe people who become blind.
And they range from people who can visualize
very well.
And people who don't visualize.
On the one hand, John Hull, who, I guess,
doesn't visualize whereas the other fellow,
Zoltan Torey, can fix the roof on his house.
>> Dr. Sacks: Well, this was a surprise to
me because I had seen a book by John Hull
as a book he dictated as he became blind in
his 40s.
And he laments that after awhile, he can no
longer visualize or imagine the faces of his
wife or children.
Even says he can't visualize a 3.
He has to make it in the air and use a sort
of performance memory instead of iconic memory.
And when I wrote about him, I assumed this
was true of all blind people.
But I got many, sometimes outraged, letters
from blind people saying that they on the
contrary, despite having lost their sight
20 years earlier, still lived in a very visual
world and sometimes in a hyper visual world.
And there is this paradoxical species of the
visual blind.
>>Presenter: So there's no way of knowing
if Hull, for example, prior to becoming blind,
was very good at visualizing or not to know
that then.
Torey, wasn't he quite--.
>> Dr. Sacks: The other man was a very good
visualizer.
His father was a film director and he would
always ask his son to visualize scenes.
I am not sure about Torey's vision before.
>> Presenter: Or Hull or Torey.
>> Dr. Sacks: I'm sorry, I mean Hull.
>> Presenter: Yeah.
>> Dr. Sacks: And I don't know what determines
the sort of thing when Torey was -- as a young
Hungarian who went to went to Australia and
was working in a chemical factory.
A vat of acid exploded in his face.
And he couldn't speak for awhile.
But he was then told forget vision.
Pay attention to your other senses.
And he determined that he wouldn't but that
he would try to make a virtual reality of
sight.
And he seems to have done so very successfully.
>> Presenter: And he really fixed his own
roof.
>>Dr. Sacks: And he fixed his own roof one
night.
And the neighbors were appalled.
[laughter]
>> Dr. Sacks: But he's fine at night.
Whereas other people are not.
I'm going to add something.
>> Presenter: Okay.
>> Dr. Sacks: Tantalizingly.
Beside the blind who lose imagery and the
blind who have very good imagery, there is
a third group.
And these are the blind who hallucinate.
And something like 15 percent of people who
are blind have very vivid hallucinations.
These were described in the 18th century.
But however, that is the opening story of
my next book.
>> Presenter:I was told not to ask about that.
[laughter]
>>Male #1: Oh, I was wondering following along
on the vision part.
Could you talk -- or do you know much about
those who are blindsided?
People whose visual processing isn't entirely
there but their eyes--
>> Dr. Sacks:Did you say blindsided or blind-sighted?
>> Male #1: S-I-G-H-T.
Blind sighted.
I read about them previously and I also had
some questions
>> Dr. Sacks: Yeah, this is a fascinating
phenomenon when people who have no conscious
vision may make correct guesses as to what's
happening around them.
And this can be quite highly developed.
And blind people with blind sight can be able
to weave their way through a series of obstructions.
They seem to be equivalence to this with other
senses.
Although deaf hearing doesn't have scan like
blind sight.
[laughter] But there's no reason why blind
sight should be limited to the blind.
And we probably make use of all sorts of cues
and sub-cortical cues ourselves.
>> Presenter: But you talk about an interesting
case.
Ben who used echo location to get around.
>> Dr. Sacks: Oh yeah.
The blind people sometimes talk about facial
vision.
Although this is a misnomer, but this is judging
the distance and the size and shape of objects
through partly from face but partly from echoing
the -- interpreting the echoes of one's foot
falls or one's stick.
But this boy, Ben, emitted a clicking sound
like a dolphin and became extraordinarily
expert.
So much so that some people at school didn't
believe he was blind.
He could jump onto a narrow pole and he would
even play chess.
And that is very amazing.
>> Presenter: Shoot baskets.
>> Dr. Sacks: Sorry.
>> Dr. Sacks: Yeah.
There is a YouTube of him.
Sadly he died when he was 15 or 16 from the
same malignant tumor he was born with.
>>Male #1: Following up do you know if those
who are blind-sighted are able to react very
quickly.
So if you tossed a ball to them, would they
be able to catch it.
>> Dr. Sacks: I can't give you a clear answer.
I think it might be something there.
The limit of ability is -- but perhaps I can
-- I'm full of irrelevancies may take off
in directions.
>> Presenter: That's okay.
>> Dr. Sacks: But there's another sort of
blind person who can catch a ball.
And this is someone who is -- in whom the
input from a video camera will go to a 10
by 10 grid of electrodes on the tongue.
And the tongue seems to be the most sensitive
for this . And so first one then has sort
of tongue vision.
Or you can tongue space an object around you.
And this then becomes as if visual.
And purely visual things like zooming and
looming and turning and perspective.
And one could probably do a good deal better
with anatomically there's no reason why one
should have 1,000 electrodes on the tongue.
>> Presenter: Go ahead.
>>Male #2: So one common thread through a
lot of your writing is the really amazing
ability of people to adapt to disabilities.
I was just wondering in your experience are
there particular traits -- or characteristics
of people that make them better or worse able
to adapt to these sorts of things.
>> Dr. Sacks: Well, there's adaptation at
every level.
And all sorts of adaptations are quite automatic.
I mean, to give you a non-neurological example.
At one time it would be found that if elderly
people might have a rather slow pulse.
And you would give them thyroid to make the
pulse quicker.
But that would drive them to heart failure
or worse.
One realizes the slow pulse is an adaptation
to being old and having less cardiac reserve.
The adaptation.
The people who survived concentration camps,
to go to the other extreme, tended to have
firm but quiet faith like Quakers.
But in general, I think it may just depend
on one's openness as an individual.
And also trying to do things.
For example, I was a stereo buff.
An ardent member of the New York Stereoscopic
Society before this happened.
Like many people there I think I depended
excessively and sometimes almost exclusively
on binocular cues.
And now I've lost that.
I have to learn to do better with monocular
cuings.
I'm not doing as well as I should.
That's partly because I'm old.
But in fact adaptation and learning continue
till the moment of death.
You may never know -- I'm sorry I'm going
to jump ahead.
Yeah, I'll mention the tongue again.
One of the people I describe in the book is
a novelist; a very good crime novelist who
came down to breakfast one morning then went
out to get the paper, the Toronto Globe and
Star, and found that unintelligible.
It seemed to be written in some peculiar language
which he compared to Korean and to Serb or
Croat.
To something.
This was devastating for him.
He was able to write.
People who have this sort of Alexia can write
freely, but they can't read what they've written.
But after a month or so, he found he could
very slowly read handwriting.
In fact handwriting rather better than printing.
And he thought he was getting better, but
when he was tested, there was zero neurological
recovery.
But what was going on, what started with the
finger, he was involuntarily unconsciously
copying the shape of letters with his tongue
on the back of his teeth or the roof of his
mouth.
So he was reading by tongue writing.
So the tongue is useful.
[laughter]
>> Dr. Sacks: There are a lot of stories about
the tongue.
When I wrote a visual book, I didn't expect
the tongue to come in twice both as a sensory
organ and as a modal organ.
I don't know if you've seen maps of how the
human body is represented in the brain.
But there's a thing called the sensory homunculus
which has an enormous tongue in hand.
The motor homunculus; the similar.
I'm sorry.
I'm getting away completely.
>> Presenter: No, this is what this is about.
>> Male #3: Still on the topic of vision and
adaptation.
>> Dr. Sacks: Yeah.
>> Male #3: I remember one of the patients
from an Anthropologist on Mars, where somebody
who had lost their vision at a very, very
young age.
And then it was repaired.
I wonder if the person was an adult.
And I think they were having trouble redeveloping
the part of the mind that processes vision.
So I was wondering, what do we know about
our ability to learn things that we would
have learned normally at a very young age.
Is the adult brain generally able to recover
some of those functions?
Or adapt in a totally different way to get
same functionality or how does that work.
>> Dr. Sacks: Well, sort of notions of an
optimal age and a critical age and a small
window.
I've lost a little bit of their strength.
Now in fact someone who you know, there are
a number of language-less, deaf people who
have never been exposed to formal sign language.
And who just develop a repertoire of few gestures
or home sign.
A friend and colleague of mine, and now of
yours, wrote me some years ago about a 27-year-old
man and his acquisition of language.
And it was all very puzzling and sort of Noam
Chomsky-like, but the notion of this is being
extended.
With the particular man you refer to, sight
was probably poorish when he was born.
And nonexistent after a few months.
And when he was given sight at the age of
50, he couldn't make anything of it.
When they sort of took the bandages off and
he seemed to be staring vacantly.
And it wasn't until the surgeons said, "well",
then he slowly homed in because he knew that
voices come from faces.
But in that time, all he could see were variously
pink surfaces and some movement.
He thought "is this seeing?"
He hadn't learned to see.
He hadn't learned to recognize.
Normally one does in the first weeks and months
of one's life.
Sight is correlated with other senses.
In fact, he did very badly.
And it was a relief to him -- although regarded
as a tragedy by others--, when he then lost
his sight again.
But others can adapt pretty well.
>> Male #3: So there are other cases of people
who've successfully relearned to see when
the physical repair occurred do you know.
>> Dr. Sacks: There are now some better cases
and things don't look as hopeless as they
did.
Although all sorts of other things.
>> Presenter: Inspired by a father in one
of your books who said of his daughter -- autistic
daughter I believe -- she loves us as much
as she can.
Would you define quote unquote 'human' by
more intellectual characteristics or emotional
ones?
Which aspect do we more tightly identify with?
This is not my question.
This is a Googler question.
>> Dr. Sacks: Oh, I see.
Emotion is certainly crucial for bonding.
And bonding is crucial for becoming human.
The people who have children with Down's syndrome
find no difficultly; can adore their children
and be adored by them.
There's an emotional fullness even though
there is fairly severe intellectual limitations.
With this young autistic girl, it was the
other way around.
But [pause] There is no one on the planet
-- there's no human being on the planet at
the moment who hasn't -- yeah, the human beings
who are furthest from the criteria of being
human are feral children who've been put out
in the forest that have somehow survived whether
they're nurtured by wolves like Mowgli or
whatever.
I don't know.
But people like this have no language.
Apparently no capacity for getting language.
And severe intellectual limitations.
And I think they are -- there's a clumsy way
of saying that a huge amount of being human
depends on culture.
You can't have a human being without culture
whereas I think you can have a cat without
culture.
[laughter] And maybe an ape.
Although there is obviously some degree of
culture and training occurs.
I think I would define human beings in terms
of self-consciousness.
Consciousness of themselves as a distinct
person.
And of having a life and of looking back on
the life and anticipating death.
I don't know whether other animals anticipate
death.
>> Presenter:There's something -- you just
made me think of this, so now I'm going to
read this.
The very end of the book, you write the following
"language, that most human invention can enable
what, in principle, should not be possible.
It can allow all of us, even congenitally
blind, see with another person's eyes."
So somehow I thought of that as you were speaking.
That it's -- you don't exist in isolation,
but you're actually experiencing -- you can
experience through others.
>> Dr. Sacks: Yeah.
Well certainly Helen Keller's autobiography
is full of vivid as if visual and auditory
descriptions.
And.
>> Presenter: Is
this another thing that kind of makes us human?
It's the cultural but it's the language.
>> Dr. Sacks: Oh, absolutely.
And also gesture.
The apes gesture a little, but only very little.
And gesture and music and language are almost
exclusively human.
>> Presenter:That's interesting because one
of the first things Ildefonso, who was Susan
Schaller's subject, 27-year-old who was deaf
and didn't learn until she worked extensively
with him to help him get the concept of naming.
I guess the word cat was the first word he
learned that he was naming something.
That he immediately started pointing, gesturing.
Which struck me as something like you said
apes don't do.
But even almost just at the cusp of linguistic
behavior.
He was pointing.
>> Dr. Sacks: The Merlin Donald who was a
remarkable psychologist -- there was a whole
cognitive cultural stage which he calls Mimetic.
And we still have this although we've now
gone onto -- he speaks of ape culture as episodic
and then mimetic and then our culture as partly
theoretic.
But it's highly mimetic as well.
And one of the stories I tell in here is an
intelligent woman who became severely aphasic
and lost the use of expressive language and
wasn't very good at understanding language.
But she became a sort of genius of gesture,
both of understanding people's gestures and
expressions and her own.
Assisted by a wordless, she couldn't get a
sentence but she could get various words.
But it's incredible how much and also can
be conveyed by mimesis.
But also how little you can't make a proposition.
It's difficult to say the cat is on the mat
or let alone anything more complex.
>> Male #4:Yeah, I'm curious.
Given what you've learned and potentially
what you would like to learn, what could we
do to make Google more useful to you.
>> Dr. Sacks: Well, I love receiving letters
from people telling me of their situations.
This sometimes becomes overwhelming and my
assistant Haylie, and Kate who is with me,
sort of have to sort these out.
But -- is that -- but can you -- I'm sorry
can you clarify for me the sort of help you
have in mind.
>> Male #4: Actually, sort of imagine that
you are in charge of Google engineering, what
would you have us build?
What would you have us change?
If you were in charge.
>> Dr. Sacks: Well, I'm afraid I don't know
very much about Google engineering.
[laughter] You know, I'm a creature who still
uses a fountain pen and a two finger typewriter.
I'm not -- although you're the search engine,
aren't you.
>> Male #4: We do a bit of that [laughter]
.
>> Dr. Sacks: You would have to tell me more
about Google that I might be able to answer
your question.
>>Male #4: Another time.
Thank you.
>> Dr. Sacks: Okay.
>>Female #2: Sorry.
This question is about adaptations again.
So there's ones that are taught, like the
tongue electrode example.
Then there's ones.
>> Dr. Sacks: Sorry, a bit slower.
>> Female #2: So there are adaptations that
are taught like the tongue electrode example
with the mapping.
And then, there are ones that people come
up with automatically.
So between those two in your experience does
one work better than the other usually?
And are there ones universal enough that we
can learn something from that to guide the
neuroplasticity -- basically teach them better.
>> Dr. Sacks: yeah.
Well, certainly the automatic ones are the
first two to alter the brain either by activating
latent or dormant connections and perhaps
later by major changes.
But all learning alters the brain, whether
it's automatic or not.
I may have missed part of your question, I'm
sorry.
>> Female #2: No, I was just wondering if
there's something that's universal about the
automatic adaptations that people do that
we could learn something from that to teach
it better.
>>Presenter: To teach it better -- to teach
>> Dr. Sacks: I'm not quite sure how -- I
mean, let me be specific.
If you reduce to monocularity, you will start
to deal with monocular clues like perspective
and occlusion better.
But this also needs to be taught to some extent.
And I'm sorry, I'm not quite sure how to deal
with the question.
I'm probably averting it.
>> Female #2: Thank you.
>> Male #5: Some years ago there was a fellow
who put together a belt made out of pagers.
>> Dr. Sacks: What.
>> Male #5: Pagers -- you know those little
things that buzz when you get a phone call.
>> Dr. Sacks: Yeah, I've heard of them.
[laughter]
>> Male #5: And the one that was facing north
would buzz.
And he said after awhile he gave himself an
inherent compass.
The sense of north and south.
That when he took it off, he became disoriented
and so forth.
A lot of what you talked about -- the majority
of what you talked about is how to cope with
some form of pathology.
But, you know, we've seen that in some ways
it's possible to -- that these systems of
adaptations also work in healthy people.
That you can in a way manufacture new senses.
Do you see this as being useful.
>> Dr. Sacks: Although I don't mention it
in the book it happens that Stereo-Sue whose
husband was an astronaut and who herself lacks
any sense of direction.
But she is much helped by a magnetic hat,
which her husband designed which emits a beep
when she is facing north.
And this is -- when she wears this, she gets
a feeling of a magnetic field.
She feels she's almost as good as an insect
or a bird with magnetite globules in the brain.
But when she takes the hat off, I don't think
there's any residue.
>> Presenter: There's a great video on YouTube
where she described -- she puts a hat.
>> Dr. Sacks: Oh, really?
I didn't know that.
She's getting around [laughter] I will speak
to her about that.
>>Presenter: It's that hat [laughter]
>>Dr. Sacks: I had an experience which startled
me some years ago when I -- I'm very fond
of the powerful rare earth magnets.
And I had a whole pocket full of them.
And as you know they tend to align themselves
with the earth's magnetic field.
And I was walking.
And as I turned around the corner, I felt
a shifting in my pocket.
You know, as if it was an animal there.
And I then wondered about perhaps putting
things on the rim of one's glasses or one's
ears.
New senses.
Would you like some new senses?
[laughter] .
>>Male #6: It couldn't hurt.
>> Dr. Sacks: Well, that's the question.
[laughter]
Now, with a friend and colleague of mine who
was congenitally totally color blind, but
intrigued by the -- by what color seemed to
mean for the rest of us.
I once asked him -- in fact, several times,
I said, "if it were possible -- if we could
give you color -- would you like it?"
And he said, "no."
He said because he has constructed -- his
brain had constructed -- a complete world
in terms of luminosity and outline and texture
and movement and depth.
And color would have no meaning.
And it would confuse him.
And then, I asked my question again.
And he turned on me and he said, "would you
like x-ray vision?"
And I thought and shuddered a bit and said,
"no, I'm okay as I am."
And he said, "so am I." [laughter] But nonetheless,
if I could optionally have some senses.
A friend of mine who was born with cataracts
and had them operated on fairly young, but
he doesn't have implanted lenses.
He has these old fashioned very thick glasses.
He once told me he could see a little way
into the ultraviolet.
And in particular he could see the honey guides
on flowers which bees use.
And I said, "what's ultra violet like?"
Salivating.
And he said he could no more tell me than
I could tell him what stereoscopy was like
which he doesn't have.
This by way of saying there's an infinite
gulf between experience and description.
But what senses would you like?
I mean, maybe Google could help.
[laughter] .
>> Presenter: So do we have time for one more
question?
One more question?
Okay, apologies to.
>> Male #7: Given the nature of your work.
You've dealt with people who have senses then
lost them or-them then gained them think in
different ways adapt and cope.
How has that affected the way you view your
humanity, your senses, your capabilities.
>> Dr. Sacks: Sorry.
>> Male #7: How was your experience with dealing
with these people who have different capabilities
affected how you personally look at your own
capabilities.
>> Dr. Sacks: I'm still missing things.
Are you saying how is my coping compared to
theirs.
>> Male #7: How do you view yourself differently.
>> Presenter: Given your experience with these
other people -- am I saying that.
>> Dr. Sacks: Well, I think often I would
hope that if what has happened to them, then
happened to me, I would do as well as they.
I've -- I mean, one of the reasons I've given
my own case history in the book as well as
others was partly to compare things.
But I think what I want to say is that coping
strategies should be shared and broadcast.
For example, one of my stories is about face
blindness or difficulty recognizing faces.
Which I have fairly severely.
Some people have overwhelmingly.
Others may have it quite severely but not
even know it because they have so automatically
used other cues of voice and dress and posture
and context.
But strategies for dealing with face blindness
should be widely known.
And is that?
That's not the sort of thing Google does.
No.
>> Presenter: Actually.
[laughter]
>>Dr. Sacks: and so, I -- you know, all culture
and civilization depends on bottling and learning
and sharing.
And I think this needs to be so far adaptations.
>>Presenter: Well, on that note, thank you
very much for coming to Google.
[Applause].
>> Dr. Sacks: Thank you
[applause]